[Music]
well your money your life has a long
history it's not just a couple of people
had a good idea and decided to be famous
and write a book
Joe developed the program it's Joe
Dominguez my co-author developed the
program in your money your life in the
1960s so that was a decade in
development and it was only for himself
only for his own early retirement he
just felt like financial service was
like military service you like to get
through it because the real stuff of
life is is through the other door the
door out of wage slavery or paid
employment and I met Joe after he had
become financially independent he I had
some savings he explained what he'd done
and made a lot of sense to me for a very
different reason from him from for me I
had was a recent college graduate and
I'd started on a professional track I
graduated from Brown University I had
lots of good prospects but it just
didn't make any sense to me to sell all
my intelligence time you know creativity
you know so like narrow that focus down
into somebody else's agenda I wanted to
be free honestly and well I was in my
20s and we understand that don't we and
so I applied his tools and it freed me
up to have a minimum income but be able
to have maximum adventure so fast
forward in the early 1980s people began
to be interested in like why was Joe
financially independent why was I not
having to work when they had to go back
to work you know they'd meet us on their
vacation and they'd go back to work why
don't we have to go back and so he
started to develop like like a first I
did this then I did that then I did that
so he developed with his become the the
Holy Writ of the nine step program but
it was just really him describing his
own process over the 1980s we produced
live seminars and then a tape course so
that this word could get out you know
it's like I approach to money number one
if we define financial independence as
the process of liberating your mind and
liberating youself from debt and
developing savings this everybody needs
to be on this path this it's a self
preservation path
so it's not I'm not talking about
freeing your time forever getting you
know pulling the trigger as they say in
the fire movement and getting
financially independent as a matter of
fact that becomes a problem for a lot of
people because they don't know what to
do with their time it's an identity
crisis you know suddenly your boss or
your profession or your you know your
context is not defining how you spend
yours of your day you're free oh dear
now you have to do it so I don't think
that's the ultimate goal as a matter of
fact I I distinguish between work job
income and identity you know those are
four things that all go in the category
of job so if you haven't thought about
Who am I what is my work in life apart
from like like my job is what I do for
money but but your work is more of a
social role or a spiritual calling you
know your work is everybody's work is to
be a good person boom that's know that's
a basic assignment we all got that one
to be a moral human being that takes
work you know self education takes work
so I would hope that people start to
think about that that you know somebody
who's a family man and he has a you know
sort of paygrade job gets out of you
know gets out of debt realizes that
money doesn't buy happiness invest a lot
and being with his grandkids that's
somebody who is becoming financially
independent in my book so that's one
part of it is that we have to stop
thinking about some lala land thing
where we're going to get out of
everything because we don't want to we
don't we can we will be working until
the day we die granny is going to be
like you know helping out in you know
with the grandkids and work is actually
what we'd love to do we love to belong
and we'd love to make a contribution and
we love to be appreciated for what the
gifts that we bring that is a lifelong
task
so I just wanted to say that that the
financial independence path really is
freeing up your life from debt and from
the obsessive desire you know obsessive
materialism so there are certain things
one is that I'm not saying everybody
should pull the trigger and free up
their time to have an identity crisis
and an existential angst about what do I
do with my time because it's a process
of freeing yourself you know this this
combination of values and dreams and
dollars and cents in a very pedestrian
way and and a sort of decloaking of the
the dynamics of the consumer culture so
people can see that the things they
think they want are very often ideas
that are planted in their heads
we're not giving people back their lives
they were they go they read the book
they get onto this program and they just
like go I'm taking it you know I'm gonna
take my life back because this game is
not worth the candle this is not equal
to who I really am this is not a noble
path and I am going to change so long
history but you know came out of just
one guy you know when he was 12 years
old at PS 81 in New York City he had to
write an essay about you know what do
you want to be when you're 30
he said financially independent
[Music]